歡迎回來趙花
好你說
今天的夜盤
因為我們錄影的同時
夜盤已經開了
沒錯
夜盤怎麼了
夜盤呢被我們這個
又是川普啦
然後川普呢一句話
又把我們這個期貨的夜盤
要弄軟了
弄軟了 他講了什麼
他講說呢
我跟這個伊朗的
停障備忘錄呢
應該是已經結束了
哈哈哈哈
不是
怎麼可以有人這樣
其實是沒有結束的
因為法律還是有效嘛
只是他單方面的說
他們覺得談不下去了
是
對 然後就造成股市又一波震盪
這是多事之秋耶
你看今天好像早上
好像開開心心的這樣
對啊 然後就又風雲變色
可是我覺得這一切都是川普的手段
自從他干預股市開始
例如說他現在講跌下去
過幾天他如果說
我跟伊朗又和好了
那航空又回來
繼續照著簽署走
是
又變成爆噴
所以又是TACO嘛
對
所以回來應該要買
好像永遠都是TACO
嗯 沒錯
好 所以我們今天的大萊甸
他在這段時間
也見識到川普這種能力
把東西弄軟的能力
好 那他專門喜歡看的是
籌碼
而且跟川普可能有同樣的嗜好
我們先來
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的籌碼高手
籌碼大人全鎮小哥
嗨 怎麼是
哈哈
一樣的嗜好是什麼
什麼嗜好
小哥說嗨
嗨
好 艾倫講什麼嗜好
就是把股票弄軟的
把股票弄軟
常常這樣
其實以前哥不是這樣
我跟哥搭配的時候
哥是喜歡把股票弄硬的
把股票弄硬的
為什麼現在4號變了呢
因為盤勢最近有點震盪
很多千金股你去看
其實都是空頭走勢
很恐怖
千元以上股票很多
都是月線下彎主力賣
那這種其實
開完漲其實都是讓你逃命的
因為哥其實如果說是做股票的話
其實也不管是多跟空
比較有肉 比較容易賺
這個才是重點
好 我們也來簡介一下
雖然我想大家對你已經很熟悉了
當初認識小哥
就是因為小哥在網路上面
每天秀對賬單
我想說哪來的
對不對 有毛病
對 為什麼要給人家看呢
但是呢
就是從看籌碼開始
也讓市場有了看籌碼的概念
跟著大戶做
從10萬塊錢滾出上億元的身家
專職操盤
每天操盤有這個所謂的交易癌
交易癌
您的座右鳴是什麼
贏要衝 輸要縮
那現在呢
現在是假設你是都做多的話
現在是個縮的時候
要縮起來 要縮你的部位
好縮
要縮小你的槓桿
這個我覺得未來可能會有一段
这个比较残酷的去杠杆时间
这个都要小心
因为现在很多人都六代通膛
那六代通膛
你假如全部都多担的话
其实最近过得有点不大愉快
你的部位最好要缩一点
因为最近很多股票都涨不上去
但是你自己也开杠杆啊
你说人家
那开杠杆像我开杠杆
我是聪明的开杠杆
什么叫聪明开杠杆
就是我的杠杆里面会有多有空
所以有多有空
你的部位大就比較不用擔心
像川普現在這樣子講
夜盤跌了1000點
那我的部位有點空單的話
其實這空單在明天是會獲利的
那它可以幫我避免我多單的虧損
它就讓我的維持率不會掉太多
因為做槓桿最怕維持率掉
是 好 這邊的話
就是有熟悉籌碼的流向
決定短線獲利
但是等一下也會講
其實你的配置也是有長有短
高亢感嘛 刚刚讲了一笑波大
大赚小赔
我想这个真的是在股票市场
长期置胜的一个纪律
对 我觉得小赔非常重要
我常常讲小赔
就是你最好的朋友
最好的朋友
当你面对小赔
你不想理他的话
接下来可能就大赔来找你了
所以我觉得大赚小赔很重要
好 这个是介绍一下我们小哥
大家可能很熟悉小哥
也要理解
小哥为什么会开始学筹码
而且专精于筹码
是因为也曾经有过资产归零
归零高的惨痛经验
对啊 那以前不会做股票
股票做一做 钱变少了嘛
那钱变少了
想说那现在买股票也没啥意思了
那来去买个全证好了
买全证就归零了
因为全证归零就是
你不愿意面对亏损
是
不愿意面对亏损
你就不想把它卖掉嘛
那不想卖掉全证又有时间价值
每天这样流失
有事到后来在到期日前呢
他就归零了
所以我们常讲面对权政
亏损你一定要面对他
面对他 处理他 放下他
其实我们有拜访过小哥
你记得吗
然后呢他的有一间
房子里面有一间教室
本来想说是要当这个理化教室
结果后来变成操盘教室
变理财教室
就是因为有这些经验
面对是一个很重要的经验值
那为什么会变成说
你觉得筹码最重要
因为之前做股票都凭感觉
这个凭感觉呢
怎么做怎么错
那有筹码之后
其实做股票比较有底了
那再加上那个我对那个
主力筹码的研究
还有现行的研究
那其实对
对整个股票的进出的位置
会比较有心得
好 不过我也很想要问小哥
我们虽然知道这些大户啊
可能他们很厉害
他们也有输的时候啊
对不对
所以基本上刚刚讲到的
大赚小赔原则
会体现在你的配置上面
对 没错
那我们先来看我的
目前的所有部分的配置啊
最重要就要现金
现金为王
而且你有现金
每天可以做大量的交易
你假如没有现金的话
相信很多散户都没有现金
已经买到没钱
买到没钱了
那只能眼睜睜的看著它跌
那要賣呢
感覺就是要停損
那有些人呢
他又不想停損
然後他錯失很多交易的機會非常可惜所以我們說這個在總是在所有交易裡面呢最重要就是你要有現金部位那第二
這個目前的多單部位
大概佔30%
只有30%
對 就30% 現金40%
因為這個多單呢
可以這個有的是長多的部分
那現金呢
是你每天可以變短多
或是短空的部分
那多單呢 就30%就夠了
那我還有空單部分
在哪裡 空單呢
20% 我不信
那20%呢
這個20%他會每天換
小哥20%可能是數字
%數是%數
金額是金額
對
20% 多空要這樣配置
那目前為止他也是偏多來做
但是那個偏多的比例越來越小
因為高檔震盪了
你這邊還有債券留個10%
大家可能想不到小哥有賣債券
债券就是一個就領配息
這個實質有點沒味道
但是至少有一個固定的收益
那你為什麼不把它all in到
因為之前就買了
買了反正就固定配息也不錯啦
就拿來當出國的錢
那才當出國的錢
當旅費
所以這邊的話就有講到
放大部位的時候
就因為這樣的配置
不會擔心
不用擔心
那第二個呢
波動率大增就要戒慎恐懼
最近台股的波動率
已經來到30幾%了
這有點恐怖了
60%就是崩盤
60%就崩盤
現在已經到30幾%了
風浪很大
你看每天夜盤
每天都震盪間點
昨天我在看夜盤
我在想說
到底是阿根廷會起死回生
還是夜盤起死回生
結果是阿根廷
夜盤沒有
逆轉勝
今天在看夜盤會不會起死回生
是
夜盤沒有美希
夜盤沒有裁判
是
欸
然後被Viva剪掉
哈哈
那這個後面呢
這個要追蹤波段權政
波段權政也蠻重要的
通常波段權政會買的大貨
都是有點消息的
然後最後一個鎖定分點大貨
是
那分點大貨的行為呢
常常就是會決定
這場股票的漲跌
這樣基本面你都不看嗎
基本面加減看
基本面就看趙华艾伦說
上面會有些
裡面會有講
因為小哥我們之前有聊過
像小哥也喜歡夾娃娃
然後之前又是數學老師
對 所以我發現小哥其實在裡面
他找的不是賺錢的機會
他找的是BUG
對不對 好像有一點這種感覺
其實交易裡面很多BUG
像台股最大BUG就是儲置股
儲置股就是個BUG在
因為他讓有些人買股票
買股票得入金嘛
賣股票可以 都可以賣
那就造成那個供需不對等
供需不對等就容易超跌
超跌就是個BUG
你在超跌的時候進場
後面就很容易引來超漲
你們兩個有共通的語言
因為我有發現小哥的嗜好是什麼
對BUG 像我們去夾娃娃就是
其實這些夾娃機的店家
他都把娃娃機調得蠻難的
但是百密終有一輸
他終於一台他沒有調好
那一台就把它弄爆他
股票要弄爆他
有BUG在就好玩
有BUG在
然後或者是要巧角度
對不對
這些都會是一個經驗值
那這個近期的代表作
就是用個股期
所以剛剛講到
雖然叫大家不要開槓
可是小哥卻因為
個股期可以躲過
這個儲置股的BUG
所以特別喜歡用個股期
對 個股期
因為個股期
它的走勢會跟個股類似
那有時候個股因為處置而下跌
它就會導致個股期
會有一個很好的買點
或者這檔股票要進處置前
它因為進處置之後
它很容易跌
它就會造成個股期有一個很好的空點
多空都可以做
是 好 所以這是最近
有在交易的個股期有可乘
可乘不是你長期持有的嗎
才是有 那到我們的存股變標股
前陣子不是因為它納入AI
就從180元拉到240元
而這一段就把它賣賣
那台光電也是處置期間
處置期間就很好玩
因為它還有時間差
所以這個小台光電跟大台光電
還有台光電股票
這中間可以套來套去
三個標的套來套去
三批 就是三個一起玩
三個一起玩
各股期貨一起玩
群創呢
群創也是 群創是因為被關
這一天被關
被關你看這邊是賺300多
整體的數字更大
整體的口數更大
這也是因為來來回做
所以是被關的時候去放空嗎
對 被關前放空
被關前放空
但是如果在背關的期間
如果又有低點
又可能把它買回來
又做多
哦
對 所以來回做
好
利用事件做
這個真的是
你看吧 我剛剛說小哥有交易癌
就是這樣子
沒有辦法不交易
所以禮拜五還是不要放假
放假的話你要怎麼交易
剛剛講到儲置股
小哥有提到儲置股就是台股的BARG
沒錯
那他在這個BARG他超級喜歡
因為會有浪子回頭股
對 沒錯
讓子回頭就讓你找買點
那處置股常常會有一個
不錯的機會
那不錯的機會呢
這個是用數據去判斷的
那我們有數據判斷的準則
那數據判斷準則就是讓子回頭
那讓子回頭呢
我們有第一個條件
月線斜率大於1
斜率大於1怎麼量
什麼叫斜率大於1呢
以前我們看那個
看新聞啊 看電視啊
你看這個月線45度
我就覺得很奇怪
45度那不是
你把那個月線把它拉開一點
縮小一點 那個角度就變了
就是你抓的時間不一樣
那角度就不一樣所以我覺得用角度來看好像沒那麼客觀其實最好的是用那個斜率來看那斜率1什麼意思呢
1代表說這個月線的均值呢
每天多1%
月線均值每天多1%
那就是標股了
標股 所以月線斜率大於1
是標股
那第二個呢 未接小於是
什麼叫未接小於是
未接小於是
這個我們之前
在歌有仇必报
有提到
那个月线呢
月线的位置我们定为位接0
上通道定为10
所以它在上通道跟月线的中间偏下面
不领通道的上通道
位接小一次
它就算一个有效的回档
那我们再看主屋主石呢
只要大于0
都是一个很好的买点
主屋主石还是帮赵豪安任
所有朋友介绍一下
就是主力5天和10天的筹码集中度
越高越好
那像在昨天呢
我就去买一档这个储置股
在里面吗
在里面叫南亚
他今天涨停了
哇塞
各位看一下他的位阶来到5
但昨天的位阶大概在0的位置
因为今天涨停
对
昨天位阶大概在4的地方
昨天大跌
但是他的筹码很漂亮
頭髮很漂亮 然後去買
今天就拉長一點 今天很強
是
所以儲置股裡面的浪子回頭
選到南亞
南亞 今天噴出
其他的呢
其他的今天有買一檔
那個後面會講
哦 趕快到後面去
這個方法我們來看一下
像之前環球金在這個位置
對
這位置 你看
好買一點嘛 你看這邊是儲置
對
這個位置回到月線好買一點
在這裡儲置回到月線好買一點
在这里储置回到月线好买点
你看这些都是浪子回到好买点
好 这边也教大家一下
所谓的储置股
不灵通道化出来
月线要上升
所以只要在储置中回到上升的月线
都是好买点
这边都是储置的时间
对喔
那现在放出来了
现在放出来了我们就不管它了
放出来回到月线也不管它吗
我们玩的是有储置的股票就好了
有储置股票就玩不玩了
那种没有储置的后面怎么样不知道
所以如果要再玩
就是他要再被關
對 等他被關
他本來有機會被關
這兩天講強一點的話
有機會被關
不過躲過了
不過哥是希望他被關
希望啊
另類懸古法
對啊 因為只要被關
你看我們這邊
很常我們每次都在理財達人區
有講到
環球金回到月線
比較快買
這邊是政府送紅包
所以這個有人一直說
把處置的機制關掉
我勸他別多管閒事
哈哈哈哈
關掉你就沒有這種好買點了好不好
不過我們確實會被卡住
就會覺得交易不方便對不對
這就是BUG
線倉電
倉電也是啊
你看月線上升嘛
回到月線是不是好買點
月線上升回到月線是不是好買點
也都是處置期間喔
是
可是現在又被放出來了
而且現在跌破月線
現在跌破月線了
是好買點嗎
不管了
PASS掉
不是處置就不用管
哇 哥的原則好清楚
宣布邏輯非常清楚
我們都等他放出來
你等他關進去
等他關進去
關進去的
這個回到月線的買點
他有機會上漲
為什麼 因為大家都期待他出關
期待他出關那個買期就會比較大
那出了關之後就不一定會漲了
很有可能他是最後一漲
後面就不漲了
所以果然是做特殊的生意
Z檔現在還被儲置吧 連電
連電 最近剛被關
所以昨天的買點還不錯
今天漲上去了
那因為最近的盤比較差
所以以前我們買儲置股
可能都期待有10% 20% 30%
現在可能7% 8%就很多了
那不就今天達成了
今天就達成了 對
你殺下來去買
因為一反彈大概就得賣了
好 操作頻率
也開始變得比較短一點
操作平均短 然后获利报酬短
像南亚你看昨天这个点很漂亮
这就是未接小一次的买点
但他还没有打到月线
还没 但是两根黑K大概就准备接了
准备接一点 到月线接更多
结果今天接完之后台阳去就赶快卖
这个手脚真的要很快
但是隔天有获利就得出了
因为现在你看一下
现在像这种月线上升股票
越来越少了
大部分都是月线下弯的
所以你要中股票大概且战且走
所以这个有个股期就是用个股期吗
就不要用现股了
因为现股你要去圈钱
有时候你要去拆20分钟后落在哪里
很麻烦
有个股期用个股期
比较方便
好 这边再度帮大家上一课
日电帽也被关
日电帽今天有个跌停的买点
我买到
我买到跌停
因为跌停突然是
杀一根 然後量很大
那通常那種杀一根量很大
那都是那種
這個有人被迫賣出的
那我們叫做停損哥的紅包
那今天我買到那個
跌停板的位置
拉上來耶
結果那個尾盤拉到快平盤
等同於賺到一根漲停
等同於你買平盤
然後拉漲停
所以這個組織股真的很好玩
很好玩
好 這邊的話都會是
很多的實力
而且像很多人可能是
是被動引進受傷
可是小哥卻賺了一根停板
這不公平的世界
所以來教大家
常常來聊的這個搶反彈
然後搶地板股
還有一個就是
波段權政大戶的觀察
對 那我們現在講搶反彈
那搶反彈就是
個股有出現在我們地板股的名單
那為什麼變成地板股
就是我們去算一下
它乖離這個均線
通常是月線
乖離月線到一個%數之後
到這個%數
他大概是95%就會反彈
那個點就是地板線
到了地板線又出量他就地板股地板股呢我們就把它列出來假如遇到地板股的話資金分成10等份我們有交貨其實10等份
那出現在地板股的個股列入自選
然後第一份資金呢
殺低包量搶反彈
然後第二份資金呢
假如再殺再搶
那有反彈就賣
這是地板股的做法
那波段權證呢
就是我們去看一下
分點大買的權證
有分點大買
然後你再去找買點就可以
那買點就有點像葛蘭幣的買點
因為這邊的話
這些統計其實都是要透過
專業的籌碼軟體
這邊我們以前做歌
有時候比包也有講
雖然證交所可能會有公佈一些資訊
可是像剛剛講到
你要去算怪利率什麼
因為小哥是樹里老師
所以要把它算出來
輔助於這些的工具
就更容易抓到
剛剛講到的
它是不是在地板線
它是不是波段的全鎮大戶在購買
先來講地板股的部分
好 地板股
地板股第一個
這個它有月線跟季線
通常我們看月線
那有基於地板跟小微地板
通常我喜歡看小微地板
那成交量一定要是20均量的兩倍
那這幾檔是最近有出現在地板股的名單
那地板股呢
通常它的籌碼都很爛
所以這個不用太care
因為被砍到地板
一定是大家在賣
那重點
其實重重之重是它的量
地板線一定要達到
第二個那個量
爆越大越好
兩倍是基本的
只要來到五倍幾乎都會彈
那前一陣子像台達電打下來
不是有一些爆大量嗎
那個也算嗎
它好像還沒到
還沒到地板線
宇龍我很有印象
因為他有懂的懂事詞
那一部分問題
每天跌停辦
可是每天跌停有出量
假如沒有出量
没有出量跌不停
有出量就会弹
好 那我们来看一下
这个雨龙的状况
说雨龙就来雨龙
是啊 雨龙你看
跌到这边
其实这一根就地板股了
这根地板股嘛 海跌
所以地板股的隔天抢嘛
对 所以隔天出量是不是抢
对 再隔天再抢一次嘛
后面整个弹上来
哦 那如果抢失败呢
抢失败5天后再找机会走
哦 抢失败可以凹5天吗
大概5天
因為這個我們統計下來
大概這5天都有機會談
那這邊都出了蠻大的量
越大量越有機會談
是 重點是搶到有出量的還蠻重要
因為有出量代表有另外一派人接
那沒出量就沒人接
沒人接就不會談
是 好 那羽龍後面又談上去了
好 這個是羽龍
因為那時候在跌
可能很多人想減
因為EPS很高
可是不知道什麼時候該減
就可以參考地板股的策略
是 接下来看这个最新的
最新的是昨天的
昨天的瑞云
那瑞云昨天也刹到地板线
那刚好跟布林通道下跪差不多
然后呢 这边也有点出量
但出的量没有很大
如果出的量很大的话
那个点就很值得抢
会不会最近变得很多啊
因为最近有好多股票突然都急跌
说真的 最近的地板股还不多
所以呢代表说怎么样
代表说这个盘
还没跌到可以减的位置
就是有些股票在跌
但是没有量
例如说像改版
短短几天跌25
紧缩
他那个第一档承接的量
还没那么大
所以有些股票跌到地盘
没出量
没出量你就要小心
下面的承接力道不大
所以你要大减股票的时候
大概就是有一堆地板股收
假如地板股有大概100檔
那大概就是短線的低點
其實好像從4萬年以來
很少有到場面
從來沒出現過
這個場面在去年4月看過一次
去年4月就在4月9號
那一天我已經這個磨刀禍禍
你說有來上節目
隔天想要好好的撈一把
結果當天晚上川普講的那些話
雲倒
沒有股票可以見
因為小哥每次來很興奮
講地板股的時候
我就會收到投訴
你知道我會收到什麼投訴嗎
會有留言說
趙華你不要再笑了
笑什麼笑這樣子
就代表大家真的超級賛
超級賛
其實那時候才是好買一點的
是
大家很生氣的時候是好買一點
對
我會留意的
收到留言通知大家
對 再跟我講一下
好
那接下來看波段權證
波段權證
這是最近
波段權證有買的標的
那有些呢 買一段時間
那今天來這邊特別介紹兩檔
最近剛買的
因為這邊也很多確實蠻右下角了
好 那第一個是240是漢堂
漢堂啊
漢堂呢 原大系值在這三天買的蠻多
他在讀台積電法說是不是
邊疊邊買
對啊 邊疊邊買
各位可以留意一下
好 產物工程的大廠
漢堂一定有原因
搞不好六元收很棒
又台積電法說
第二個是7788
松川金蜜
你喜歡的啊
7788不要久
欸 不知道什麼術語
我聽不懂
聽不懂
7788松川金蜜
中立哥最近買很多
買完之後還跌破
跌破買的位置
是
所以你現在買的價格是
松川金蜜買的價格還低
買的比大盤商還低
是
各位你可以留意一下
我不曉得他看到什麼
但通常買這麼多
就是有看到什麼
是 继电器的大厂
没错 也是重电相关
其实之前超级抗跌 超级航
最近才跌下来
所以波代大户有可能失败吗
有可能 也是有可能失败
但长期来看成功机会比较多
好 今天很谢谢
我们的老朋友好朋友小哥
来到现场
又再把大家教了一下
现在虽然有地板骨 但不多
如果过阵子多了
希望大家不要只是愁云产物
而是要把握机会
不要覺得我們兩個笑得很高興
其實是機會的到來
我們搶過聯發科
哈哈哈
結果後面變成4980
對啊沒錯
5倍你看
還滿精人的